>> DESPITE THE CLOSURES, IN MOST
CASES GROCERY STORES, PHARMACIES
AND GAS STATIONS WILL REMAIN
OPEN.
>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY ECHOED
CALLS FOR AMERICANS TO HUNKER
DOWN AND AVOID UNNECESSARY
TRAVEL.
>> MY ADMINISTRATION IS
RECOMMENDING THAT ALL AMERICANS
INCLUDING THE YOUNG AND HEALTHY
WORK TO ENGAGE IN SCHOOLING FROM
HOME WHEN POSSIBLE, AVOID
GATHERING OF GROUPS OF MORE THAN
TEN PEOPLE, AVOID DISCRETIONARY
TRAVEL AND AVOID EATING AND
DRINKING IN BARS, RESTAURANTS,
AND PUBLIC FOOD COURTS.
>> Laura: WHILE THIS IS A
PRUDENT PUBLIC HEALTH MOVE, WHAT
IS THE COST TO THE ECONOMY?
JOINING US NOW, I’M DELIGHTED
HE’S WITH US.
STEVE FORBES, CHAIRMAN AND OF
FORBES MEDIA.
AND JOHN, THE OWNER OF
GARCETTI’S, THE SUPERMARKET
CHAIN?
AM I SAYING THAT RIGHT?
HOW MUCH DAMAGE COULD A
NATIONWIDE LOCKDOWN DO?
SPEAK OF THE DAMAGE IS GOING TO
BE SUBSTANTIAL AND IT’S GOING TO
HURT A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS AND
PUT OUT OF BUSINESSES TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES.
SMALL AND BIG ONES AS WELL
STARTING WITH THE AIRLINES.
THAT’S WHY IT’S ESSENTIAL FOR
THE FEDERAL RESERVE TO DO NOW
WHAT HE DID 12 YEARS AGO TO
PROVIDE LOANS THROUGH COMMERCIAL
PAPER.
THEY CAN SET UP A FACILITY TO
PROVIDE MONEY, CASH TO OTHERWISE
SOLVENT BUSINESSES TO KEEP THEM
THROUGH THE STORM.
AND THE INDIVIDUAL SIDE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TO PUSH FOR
A SUSPENSION OF THE PAYROLL TAX
AND PUT MONEY IN PEOPLE’S
POCKETS BETWEEN NOW AND
YEAR-END.
SOMETHING LIKE WHAT
SENATOR COTTON IS PROPOSING, FOR
MIDDLE AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE TO
GET A ONE-TIME CHECK.
THE NICE THING ABOUT THESE
MEASURES IS THEY END WHEN THE
CRISIS ENDS, INSTEAD OF THIS
SICK PAY LEAVE AND THINGS LIKE
THAT WHICH WILL CRUSH SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE FUTURE.
DO ONE-TIME EMERGENCY MEASURES.
THEY ARE EXPENSIVE BUT THE STOCK
MARKET HAS ALREADY LOST
$6 TRILLION IN VALUE.
DO THIS AND WE WILL GET THROUGH
THE STORM AND BE PREPARED FOR
RECOVERY LATER THIS YEAR.
>> Laura: I DID MY ANGLE
EARLIER ON HOW THIS CAN’T BECOME
THE NEW NORMAL EVERY TIME A
HEALTH CRISIS OCCURS IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY AND WRECK OUR ECONOMY.
THAT CAN’T BE THE NEW NORMAL.
WE HAVE TO TAKE LESSONS FROM
THIS GOING FORWARD ABOUT HOW WE
DEAL WITH CHINA, HOW WE DEAL
WITH SUPPLY CHAINS.
HOW WE DEAL WITH TESTING IN
AIRPORTS.
YOU CAN’T SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMY
AGAIN IN THE FALL OF THIS FIRE
IS POPS BACK UP.
>> NO.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SHOULD BE
DONE ALONG THOSE LINES IN
ADDITION TO ESPECIALLY ON THE
DRUG SIDE AND THERE ARE
TECHNOLOGIES NOW OR WE CAN
VASTLY IMPROVE THE MANUFACTURING
OF DRUGS.
IN TERMS OF CHINA, THOSE THINGS
SHOULD BE DONE.
BUT ALSO I THINK IN TERMS OF THE
FUTURE, WE NEED A COMMISSION
LIKE WE DID AFTER PEARL HARBOR,
LIKE AFTER 9/11.
WHY DID THE CDC REALLY BOTCH
THIS THING UP?
WE WEREN’T PREPARED WITH TESTS.
THEY KNEW IN NOVEMBER, DECEMBER
THAT A BAD THING WAS COMING OUR
WAY AND THEY DIDN’T -- THEY
RESPONDED LIKE A BUREAUCRACY
MORE INTERESTED IN BUREAUCRATIC
RULES RATHER THAN MOBILIZING THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
CONTRAST THAT WITH SOUTH KOREA
WHICH IS ALREADY DONE EACH DAY
MORE TEST THAN WE’VE DONE SINCE
DECEMBER.
THAT’S AN OUTRAGE AND WE HAVE TO
AVOID THAT AGAIN.
NIP THESE THINGS IN THE BUD.
WE HAD EXPERIENCED WITH EBOLA,
SWINE FLU AND OTHER EPIDEMICS,
POTENTIAL EPIDEMICS.
WHY DID THEY FAIL THIS TIME?
WE NEED TO FIND OUT AND
PREVENTED HAPPENING AGAIN.
>> Laura: AND DECOUPLE FROM
CHINA WHEN IT COMES TO ESSENTIAL
PRODUCTS, MEDICINES AND MEDICAL
SUPPLIES.
WE CANNOT BE HELD HOSTAGE BY
OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> THAT WILL HAPPEN SOON.
>> Laura: JOHN, I WANT TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT THE FOOD SUPPLY.
WE HAVE HAD ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
PANIC ON THE PART OF AMERICANS
IN WANTING TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE ENOUGH FOOD FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US TONIGHT
ABOUT THAT CONCERN OF AMERICAN
FAMILIES AND HOW THEY SHOULD BE
REACTING?
>> I THINK THAT THERE’S A
SHORTAGE OF TOILET PAPER OF
COURSE.
THERE’S ALWAYS A SHORTAGE OF
TOILET PAPER.
THERE IS NO SHORTAGE OF CERTAIN
CLOROX PRODUCTS AND PRODUCTS FOR
CLEANING -- THERE IS A SHORTAGE
OF CERTAIN CLOROX PRODUCTS.
IT’S NOT ABOUT THE FED.
I DON’T THINK THE FED CAN SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM.
IT’S ABOUT GIVING PEOPLE HOPE
THAT THERE IS A OUT THERE.
THE FED HAS CUT RATES TO
NOTHING, IT DID NOT HELP.
THE FED SAID THEY WILL PROVIDE
$700 BILLION.
IT DIDN’T HELP.
THIS IS ABOUT PROVIDING HOPE TO
THE PEOPLE.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE
EVERYTHING RIGHT SO FAR.
HE HAS CLOSE THE BORDERS WHICH
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND I
THINK TRUMP IS TOUGH ENOUGH THAT
IF ONE OF THE COMPANIES HAS A
VIRUS OR VACCINE OR VERY CLOSE
TO IT, I THINK HE’S GOING TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN AND HAVE SOME
BLUE SKY OUT THERE.
>> Laura: EVERYONE WANTED
TRUMP TO BE AS FORTHRIGHT AND
SOMBER AS HE WAS TO DATE AND HE
WAS, YOU SAW THE MARKET GO DOWN
EVEN FURTHER WHEN HE WAS
SPEAKING BECAUSE HE SAID IT
COULD BE JULY OR AUGUST.
HE DIDN’T MEAN WE WERE GOING TO
BE IN OUR HOUSES UNTIL JULY OR
AUGUST BUT HE MEANT THAT THE
VIRUS COULD STILL BE
CIRCULATING.
>> I THINK THE KEY THING NOW IS
TO HAVE THE FED MAKE SURE THAT
THE SOLVENT BUSINESSES DON’T GO
UNDER AND DO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS RECOMMENDED IN
TERMS OF A PAYROLL TAX SO THAT
PEOPLE GET IMMEDIATE RELIEF AND
ALSO REDUCING THE COST OF
BUSINESSES TO KEEP PEOPLE
WORKING.
SO THAT’S WIN-WIN.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE
EMPHASIZING THOSE THINGS AS WELL
AS NOT PAINTING TOO ROSY A
PICTURE.
I THINK WILL RECOVER FROM THIS
SOONER, SOON AS WE GET TESTS OUT
THERE AND GET REAL KNOWLEDGE OF
WHAT THE FACTS ARE SO WE CAN
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY AND
LASER-LIKE INSTEAD OF SHOOTING
IN THE DARK BECAUSE OF WHAT WE
JUST DON’T KNOW.
>> Laura: WE NEED MORE